ARE THE BOSS.
ACT LIKE IT.
TEDDY VANCE IS RUNNING IN
OHIO.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
HOW IS IT IN A SYSTEM
DESIGNED TO SERVE DESIRES
AND NEEDS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT AN ELECTION OUTCOME
THE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE IS
THE END OF THE SYSTEM.
ISN'T IT IN FACT A
HEARTWARMING PIECE OF
EVIDENCE THAT THE SYSTEM
WORKS?
>> YEAH, TUCKER.
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT OUR
DEMOCRACY IS UNDER THREAT,
WHAT THEY TYPICALLY MEAN
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY CHALLENGE THE
ESTABLISHMENT MIGHT GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GOVERN
WHICH IS EXACTLY WHAT I
THINK WILL HAPPEN IN OUR
RACE AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
RACES IN ABOUT FIVE DAYS,
TUCKER.
ONE OF THE CRAZY THINGS
AND ONE OF THE REALLY BIG
WAYS IN WHICH THE
DEMOCRATS AND
ESTABLISHMENT REALLY
SUPPRESS
ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT
CANDIDATES IS BY FLOODING
THE ZONE WITH A TON OF
MONEY.
I'M RUNNING AGAINST
DEMOCRAT TIM RYAN WHO HAS
THIS TECH BACKED
FUNDRAISING PLATFORM WHERE
HE RAISED $65 MILLION,
THAT'S NOT A THREAT WHEN
THE TECH INDUSTRY PROMOTES
TIM RYAN'S FUNDRAISING AND
SUPPRESS INFORMATION ON
OUR RACE AND OTHERS, BUT
IT IS A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY WHEN PEOPLE VOTE
THE WAY THEY WANT TO
ANYWAY.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
IT IS WHY, TUCKER, PEOPLE
NEED TO VOTE.
GO TO JD
DCHL
D VAN
TO NOT LISTEN TO SENSORS
AND WARNINGS.
WE ARE FREE PEOPLE AND
NEED TO LET PEOPLE KNOW
THAT NOVEMBER 8th.
>> IF YOU BELIEVED IN
DEMOCRACY, YOU WOULD WANT
EACH CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT IN A STATEWIDE
RACE TO GET
REPRESENTATIVES THAT
CLOSELY NEAR THE VIEWS HE
REPRESENTS.
TIM RYAN WHO REPRESENTED
YOUNGSTOWN, CONSERVATIVE
DEMOCRATS, MOVED WAY LEFT,
WAY LEFT, CRAZY LEFT, AT
THE BEHEST OF HIS TON
DONORS
HOW IS THAT DEMOCRACY?
>> IT IS NOT.
IT IS OLIGARCHY.
TIM RYAN IS THE POSTER FOR
OLIGARCHY.
LOOK AT GREEN ENERGY, BAD
FOR PEOPLE OF YOUNGSTOWN
OHIO, LOOK AT VIEWS ON
FLOODING AMERICA WITH
ILLEGAL ALIENS, USING TAX
DOLLARS TO FUND GENDER
REASSIGNMENT FOR THOSE
ALIENS, THAT'S WHAT TIM
RYAN PROPOSED DOING.
YOU REALIZE THAT THIS IS
NOT ABOUT LETTING THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE DETERMINE
ELECTIONS, THAT'S NOT WHY
PEOPLE ARE THREATENING,
THAT'S NOT WHY THEY'RE
WARNING, NOT WHY THEY'RE
CENSORING, THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE IS TO GET BACK TO
COMMON SENSE, INFLATION
POLICIES TO, TO SECURE THE
BORDER, THAT'S DEMOCRACY
IN ACTION.
THAT'S A GREAT THING,
TUCKER.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY
OFFER.
THEY OFFER THE DONOR CLASS
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
CONTINUING TO CONTROL WHAT
DEMOCRATS SAY AND WHAT
ULTIMATELY HAPPENS IN OUR
GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T THINK WE'RE GOING
TO LET IT HAPPEN ANY MORE.
FIVE DAYS, TUCKER, WE SEND
A BIG MESSAGE, THAT'S NOT
HOW IT WORKS IN THIS
COUNTRY ANY LONGER.
>> LAST QUESTION, JD
ADVANCE, MAY BE THE LAST
CHANCE WE SPEAK BEFORE THE
ELECTION, AND GOD SPEED.
YOU WERE A BEST SELLING
AUTHOR, BUSINESSMAN,
DIDN'T NEED THE JOB, BIG
PAYCUT, HASSLE FOR THE
FAMILY.
YOU DID IT BECAUSE YOU
WANTED TO BE A CITIZEN
LEGISLATOR.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
CANDIDATES ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE THAT DID
THE SAME THING.
ISN'T THAT WHAT A
DEMOCRACY IS SUPPOSED TO
PRODUCE?
YET YOU'RE ATTACKED AS
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> WELL, IT IS BECAUSE I'M
NOT A THREAT TO DEMOCRACY,
TUCKER, I'M A THREAT TO
THE EXISTING POWER
STRUCTURE IN THIS COUNTRY
THAT WE HAVE TO REMEMBER
HAS GOTTEN RICH BY
SHIPPING OUR INDUSTRIAL
BASE TO CHINA AND HAS
THROWN A SET OF VALUES IN
OUR SCHOOLS, EVEN IN OUR
MILITARY ONTO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE NEVER ASKED FOR AND
NONE OF US ACTUALLY WANT.
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT
OFFSHORING AND WOKE
IDEOLOGY AND GENDER
REASSIGNMENT SURGERIES FOR
NINE-YEAR-OLD KIDS, THAT'S
ALL PART OF THE SAME
RULING CLASS SET OF IDEAS.
THOSE OF US FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST IT, AND I
CERTAINLY THINK I AM NOT
THE ONLY ONE, THOSE OF US
FIGHTING AGAINST IT ARE
DOING WHAT DEMOCRACY
DEMANDS OF US WHICH IS
TAKING THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE AND TRANSLATING IT
HOPEFULLY TO EFFECTIVE
PUBLIC POLICY THAT PUSHES
BACK AGAINST THE
CRAZINESS.
IT IS NOT A THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY, TUCKER, IT IS
THE VERY REALIZATION OF
DEMOCRACY.
I THINK OUR FOUNDING
FATHERS GAVE US A GREAT
SYSTEM, BUT WE HAVE TO
FIGHT FOR IT, AND WE HAVE
TO PRESERVE IT, AND WHEN
PEOPLE SAY WE ARE
THREATENING DEMOCRACY, WE
NEED TO IGNORE THEM.
THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE IS
DEMOCRACY AND THAT'S A
GREAT THING.